um 30 FPS
for any other reason other that we just
can't make it on time
um
feels like they're not reading the room
properly and I don't know what it is
right it could be an optimization thing
right that it's just not they're not
able to finish it on time or it could be
an issue where it isn't as much of a
priority as we would like it to be um I
want to know the second one I want to
know where you guys land because there
I've I've long thought that the idea of
60 FPS on consoles why haven't it why
hasn't this been the norm
for a long time now right and it's
always been CPU bottleneck CPU
bottleneck has has kept us from being
able to to sort of hit that but why is
there that CPU bottleneck obviously
prices and stuff like that when you talk
about consoles consoles is always a
compromise right